*Jingle Golden Moustache*
Qu'est-ce qu'un commentaire ?
"Nous entrons dans ce que sont les écoles de commentaires YouTube...
...parler......discussions......
C'est vrai qu'Internet et les nouvelles technologies progressent de manière assez exponentielle...
...et mon cours consiste simplement...
...à "mettre à la page" les personnes âgées n'ayant PAS suivi cette évolution linguistique !
Afin de leur éviter un décalage majeur lorsqu'elles commentent une vidéo YouTube.
Euh...
En gros vous êtes prof' de commentaires YouTube ?
Voilà ! C'est ça !
...
Mais j'lai mieux dit !
( Musique de Rap)
Oh ! Oh !
Un commentaire ? Micheline !
Dans l'ensemble, c'est formidable !
Mais,  j'ai trouvé que le propos était un petit peu "fort de café"...
Toutes ces insanitées...
Ce "Mr. Bas" qui fait le barbot !
C'est un cabotin !
En revanche, il a de très jolie chaînes !
Alors...
C'est très intéressant, Micheline !
Concernant... Tout ce qui est
"barbot", "cabotin"...
Ça pourrait plus se traduire, peut-être, par...
"Shnek !"
"Boloss !!!"
Boloss !
Quoi qu'un peu générique !, Michel...
Hein...
Mais, ça passe !, Ça passe !...
Oui ? Jean-Pierre !
Un p.... Un peu trop "patati-patata" !
........
Tu sors....
P'tin c'est re-lou !
'Fait ie-ch de ouf' ! là
Pour en revenir à cette histoire de chaîne !
Comment on pourrait dire, qu'effectivement, ce jeune homme à de très belles chaines ?
"Swagg !"
"Swaggy-la-Caillasse !"
"Swaggy-la-Caillasse, Frère !"
xD
Ah bah non ! Pas "xD" !
Parce que "xD" ça vient après un compliment !
Ça fonctionne pas quand il y a l'impératif ou le négatif
juste avant !
Comme par exemple dans...
"Mange ta shnek !"
Mange ta shnek !
Ça on peut pas !
Bon, t'facon on aura l'occasion de reparler de tout ça  !
Je vous dit à demain !
Et rentrez bien, et surtout "xO" !
"xO !!!"
...bra....zbra
"Cyber ma gueule !"
Ils progressent tellement vite...